hey baby I'm watching certified country
with Sophie chelation whoa oh shoot I
spilled it on my dress
[Music]
welcome back to certified country I'm
selfish lazy and listen if there's one
thing that I love more than country
music maybe more it's a close one
it's a delicious bottle of wine and
today happy hours come early y'all
because we are raising a glass with
Florida Georgia line Canaan Smith and
Little Big Town now some of you may
already be familiar with my other
youtube series called interviews under
the influence all right well here we go
yeah well one in one eye
yeah who's keeping track never have I
ever lied during this game which is
Michigan tomorrow yes the grandmas of
course involves drinking throughout the
interview and I recently sat down with
Little Big Town to swap stories over a
game of never have I ever
the band recently launched their very
own line of vino it's called for sellers
and it's real good now if you haven't
seen the full interview yet take a look
at this little gem never have I ever
have an awkward run-in with another
celebrity Oh every interaction I have
with the Blake is yeah I started
thinking about you usually we're
drinking around Blake okay what happened
is our he's just offered to join in this
while drinking or just adjure in general
yeah I felt I felt all into Dolly Parton
once okay and now when you trying to
meet her up kind of fell onto her lap
that was awkward
if you're going to fall into somebody's
lap though like I get from
okay doesn't overlap I make it to the
left there are plenty more stories where
that came from and you can watch the
full piece right here on YouTube
but honestly one of the coolest things
about what LBT is doing here is they've
launched a complete wine club it's an
experience that includes full bottles
exclusive merchandise from the band
recipes straight from Kimberly's kitchen
and customized playlists it's seriously
a brilliant idea and you better believe
that I am already a card-carrying member
of that Club
I do love my wine but it's not my only
drink of choice I also had a beer in
Nashville with kanan Smith on the
gorgeous rooftop of the Thompson hotel
this is my first time ever meeting Kanan
but it's safe to say that we became fast
friends we got to talk about these
drinks for a second though because I
have like the darkest beer ever and what
do you have there girly is don't even
notice hi but something's wrong with
this picture we need to switch I can get
my man card back oh my god results like
that I'm the Pina Colada guy no shame
that's what I do yeah
now you baby
[Music]
crazy it
why Miranda Lambert crazy hmm she's your
own kind of crazy dumb but Miranda
Lambert crazy was was the one that made
the most sense in my head I was like you
know if I'm trying to sell this idea of
a woman keeping a dude on his toes in a
way that everyone can relate to
I think Miranda Lambert crazy is the
best way to do it that's kind of crazy
she's pretty she's kind of crazy I think
I like that she is undoubtedly herself
all the time unapologetically and it's a
compliment when I say that you know that
I like you that way because it's I think
it's sexy so yeah I hope that she hears
it and thanks
[Music]
on my name
we came
I didn't meet your wife we met at a club
show that I was playing years ago before
I had any success I went out to the
crowd to just say thanks for the people
who were there and I wanted to grab a
beer and I walked up to her and I just
remember being struck by her beauty and
just overall kindness I could tell that
she was a good soul and so yeah the rest
of history was just one of those kind of
love at first sight thanks for us man
it's a real thing I know it sounds
cheesy it was real be working on right
now new songs a new album which we don't
have a street date for yet but a lot of
exciting songs and tour and all summer
long so what inspires you like what else
are you writing about I write about real
life as much as I can my first album
Bronco was was actually as real as it
gets for me I was writing from
first-hand perspective and it included
all kinds of stories about my life and
you know from the loss of my brother to
a car wreck to another brother suffering
from addiction and then and just get old
party songs you know like blow off some
steam and and just making the most of
the night I like songs that connect to
the human spirit and and so that's
that's what I'm all about that brings me
to my song picks of the week we've got
just one today and if you follow me on
social media you already know that we
aditi debuted Florida Georgia line's
brand new smooth music video earlier
this week and it was a party
[Music]
during your own good
Hey
[Music]
piqué and tyler orchestrated an epic las
vegas vow renewal for their friend and
legendary songwriter Craig Wiseman aka
cat daddy and only et has this
behind-the-scenes footage really excited
about the smooth video my first time
co-director has been really cool to
write the treatment and and see this
thing slowly come to life
like a sunny morning ever singing
gondola hello
the guys of course had plenty of old
camp whiskey on hand for the shoot and I
am here to tell you that their peach
pecan flavor is delicious between the
three of us we had about eleven shots
when I sat down with them last fall and
we definitely learned a lot about each
other that day including that t-hub
actually got catfished by an Owen Wilson
impersonator one time in Rome yeah it's
just as crazy as it sounds you're gonna
want to hear that story for yourself I
actually have a story for you I was in
Rome with me and my wife and a hotel I'd
go across the hallway to the pool
Haley's still in the gym working out and
so is Owen Wilson Haley's like Tyler you
should tweet I wouldn't listen and maybe
just see if he's a fan of country music
and maybe he just happens to want to
hang out with us and had a drink later
and so I did I got on Twitter I said
what's up man Tyler here for the doors a
lot happened to be in the same hotel
you're right and wrong a few hours go by
we're at lunch Haley's check her Twitter
he tweets me back with a little wine
glass that says yes we're showering up
getting all ready I'm going to have a
drink with Owen listen tonight so we go
down to the bar said that for about an
hour he doesn't show up so we go to the
restroom on the way out of the bar right
before walking to dinner I come out of
the bathroom sure enough here comes Owen
wheels and walking down the hallway so
I'm like what's not there is what's up
he didn't know me nor did he even have
Twitter
I got catfished by Owen Wilson in Rome
and then he turned around asked me what
band I was in again I told him Florida
Georgia line he said cool and then
walked on down the hallway
it was quite humiliating and
embarrassing and I was actually that guy
and that'll do it for another episode of
certified country hit the comments and
let me know who you want to see on the
show and don't forget to Like and
subscribe for more from ET you can find
me on instagram at Sophia lacy come back
and see us again next Friday right here
on YouTube mmm good
[Music]